PROFESSOR: So we
continue today our study
of electromagnetic fields,
and quantum mechanics,
and particles in those
electromagnetic fields.
So last time, we
described what we
must do in order to
couple a particle
to an electromagnetic field.
And the rule was oddly simple.
You get the
Schrodinger equation,
and the Hamiltonian is now
changed into this form.
If you had a free
particle, you're
accustomed to have
p squared over 2m.
That has changed, and you
have a new term, with p,
minus q over c, A squared.
Thank you.
So now our task is to understand
how this is compatible,
and what are the implications
of these changes.
They're pretty
significant changes.
This expression,
p, minus q over c,
A, is what used to be just p.
And that used to be
just the kinetic energy.
And now it looks a little
more strange, in fact.
So in terms of
electromagnetic potentials,
we know that the
potentials are not unique.
There are this gauge
transformations
that establish that these
are completely equivalent
potentials-- so two
potentials, A and phi,
and A prime and phi prime,
are physically equivalent.
They define the same
electromagnetic field
if they are related in this way.
We then mention
that therefore you
have an issue with the
Schrodinger equation.
You would want the physics
to remain invariant
in their gauge transformations.
So you could write the
Schrodinger equation
for the new gauge potentials,
with A prime and phi prime.
And you could compare with
the Schrodinger equation
with the old
potentials, A and phi.
And you could ask, OK, is
it solved by the same wave
function?
And the answer is no.
The wave function must change.
But there is a way to get one
way function from the other.
Here is the formula.
Psi prime and psi are related by
this factor, this function, U,
which involves exponential of
the gauge parameter, multiplied
by a couple of
physical constants,
including the charge,
q, of the particle.
Now we're going to use the
notation, q, all the time.
Many books put E in there.
And that's the charge
of the electron.
And then you always wonder,
is that E, or minus E,
or which sign is it.
So here, q is the
charge of the particle.
If you have an
electron, q is minus E.
But let's leave it q open there,
so you can work with arbitrary
charges in any circumstance.
So this Hamiltonian is
what we have to understand.
They want to make a
couple more comments
about what this Hamiltonian is.
And we must think a little about
the gauge invariance as well.
So there it is.
A Hamiltonian contains
this term squared.
So let's just ask
ourselves, what
does that term really imply.
Well, there's 1 over 2m.
So for the
Hamiltonian, 1 over 2m.
And we have this factor squared.
So following the
careful things we're
accustomed to do in
quantum mechanics,
I would put P squared here,
minus q over c, P dot A,
minus q over c, A dot P, plus
q squared over c squared,
A squared, plus q phi.
That's how the
Hamiltonian looks.
But you have to be careful.
Here, this term we kind
of understand what it is.
It's vector potential squared--
no problem.
Here is p squared.
We're accustomed to that.
That's a Lapacian.
We have two terms that
could be a little strange.
A dot P, probably is all clear.
A is dotted with a vector
momentum, which is an operator.
It's the gradient.
So that's going to differentiate
whatever is to the right.
The question is,
what this P dot A?
And P dot A must be thought
in the operator way,
that P acts on everything
to the right, including A.
So if this Hamiltonian is to
act in a wave function, that
doesn't mean that the P
operator just acts on A.
It acts on A and
everything to the right.
So P dot A, if you think
of it as a derivative,
is h bar over i, divergence
of A, plus A dot P. You see,
this P is h bar over i gradient,
but it's acting on everything.
So you could put up psi
to the right of here,
and it would act on
everything there.
So maybe in order to
justify this equation,
you should just write h bar over
i gradient acting on A times
a wave function, psi.
And go through this and see
that at the end of the day,
this P dot with
A means act on A,
but then you still have to act
on everything to the right.
So that's this term here.
So this term is
pretty important.
Sometimes your A satisfies what
is called the Coulomb gauge,
in which delta of A is zero,
but in general it doesn't.
So this helps clarify what
the Hamiltonian really is.
It would be a mistake
to say that these two
terms are the same.
And it would be also a mistake
to say that this thing is just
the divergence of A.
Both are wrong things.
So the whole Hamiltonian,
now, is P squared over 2m.
Then you have twice--
well, let's have this term.
So you have plus, the i
goes to the numerator,
as i h bar q, over 2m
c, divergence of A.
And that's just the
divergence of A, the function.
It's not any more a
differential operator.
It's just acted on it.
Then you have this term twice.
So minus q over mc, A dot
P, plus this term, q squared
over 2mc squared, A
squared, plus q phi.
So that's the Hamiltonian.
Let me just make
sure I got it right--
P squared over 2m, plus
[INAUDIBLE],, minus qAP--
OK, so that's right.
OK, so this is our Hamiltonian.
If you just want to
write it very explicitly.
It's not generally all
that useful to have
the explicit form.
But in some examples-- there
will be at least one example
where it is nice to know.
And in fact, the H formula
on the top of the blackboard
hides, in a nice way, a
little bit the complexity
of this whole coupling.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this
for scalar particles?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this is
for a scalar particle.
So we're taking a particle,
at this moment, without spin.
For spin particles, there
would be a little extra term
sometimes.
So let's say a couple more
words about this thing,
in particular the
gauge invariance.
So we now have seen
what the Hamiltonian is.
Let's think of the
gauge invariance.
How could you establish
this gauge invariance?
So an identity
that is very useful
takes the following form.
This differential operator--
h bar over i gradient, the p,
minus q over c, A
prime, times U--
and you could put the
psi here if you wish--
is in fact equal to U,
h bar over i gradient,
minus q over c, A, psi.
So I call this a very
remarkable identity.
And look what's happening here.
This is useful for
this kind of equation.
If you have a psi
prime which is U psi,
the factor U interacts very
nicely with this operator.
In fact, as you move U
from the right to the left,
the gauge potential
goes from A prime to A.
A rather nice thing about
this derivative-- it's
as if this derivative had
a very special symmetry
property that U can
be moved across,
almost as if U was a constant.
But of course it's not.
But when you move it
across, the only effect
is to change the A
prime to A. So a gauge
transformation on the A.
That is the reason this
derivative, equipped
with an extra term, is sometimes
called a gauge covariant
derivative.
That is, it transforms nicely
under gauge transformations.
It does a nice job.
I write this equation because,
in part of the exercises,
you will be asked to show that
this statement about gauge
transformations is correct, that
if this equation-- top-- holds,
the bottom equation holds with
the replacements indicated
here.
And this identity makes the
task of proving the equation--
the gauge invariance--
very simple.
Because you can imagine
this psi prime--
put U psi-- and then
getting the U out,
so the psi prime
just will become psi,
and the U going
through these factors
and simplifying very nicely.
So this is a simple
equation to show.
For example, I can
take the left-hand side
and see what happens.
So the first term,
you have a gradient
acting on the product
of two functions.
And that's just the
gradient acting on each.
So h over i, gradient
of U, times psi, plus U,
h over i, gradient of psi.
That's the first term.
The second term is minus
q over c, A, times U psi--
because A prime is A
plus gradient of lambda.
So you're going to
have minus q over c,
gradient of lambda, U psi.
So I wrote the first line.
Now we can take the
gradient of U. U is here.
When we take the gradient
of U, what do we get?
h bar over i, now
gradient of U--
you differentiate
the exponentials,
so you take the gradient
of what is in the exponent.
So it's iq over h bar
c, gradient of lambda,
times U itself, because
you're differentiating
an exponential, times psi.
And then you have all
these other terms.
I'll couple this term.
These two terms here are plus U
h bar over i, gradient of psi,
minus q over c.
U and A commute, because A is
a function of x and t, and U
is a function of lambda, which
is also a function of x and t.
So there's no momentum here.
These two things commute, so
U can be moved to the left--
A psi minus this term.
And if we've done
the arithmetic right,
the first and last term
should cancel, and they do.
That i cancels,
the h bar cancels,
there's q over c times that,
and there's minus that term,
so these two cancel.
And this is precisely
the right-hand side.
So this covariant
derivative is very nice.
There's something about the
Schrodinger equation of course
that, in a sense, it's all
made of covariant derivatives.
Let's look at that.
So any version of the
Schrodinger equation--
here is the typical version
of the Schrodinger equation.
So recall that the vector
potential in general
can be thought of
as a four-vector.
You may or may not have seen
this in the literal dynamics.
But it's just like time
and x form a four-vector.
The scalar potential
and the vector potential
form a four-vector.
So the four-vector with index
mu, 0, 1, 2, 3 form this.
And then, if you look at
the Schrodinger equation,
what do we have?
We have i h bar, d
psi, dt, minus q phi--
I'm bringing the last term
on the right-hand side
to the left.
So it's minus q times phi, which
is minus A0 psi is equal to 1
over 2m, this i h
bar over i gradient,
minus q over c, A,
squared, and psi.
And now look at this.
It can be written as follows.
Minus c times h over i, d over d
of ct, minus q over c, A0, psi,
equal the same thing
on the right-hand side.
So I've rewritten
the left-hand side
in a slightly different
way, all the terms.
So I put an extra
c, this d, dct.
That canceled the c.
The h bar, the i went
to the denominator.
And now this all looks like
this covariant derivative.
Look at this covariant
derivative. h over i, d dx,
minus q over c, A. And here
it is, h over i, d dx0--
because 0 is component
of the [INAUDIBLE],,
minus q over c, A0.
So the whole
Schrodinger equation
is built with this
funny derivatives-- d
dx minus the vector
potential added in the net.
These are the
covariant derivatives.
These are nice operators.
You see, the
operator P is always
called the canonical momentum--
canonical momentum.
And this canonical momentum is
a momentum such that x with P,
if you put the hat, is i h bar.
But this canonical momentum,
P, is not mass times velocity,
not at all.
This canonical momentum
is a little unintuitive.
It's the one that
generates translation.
The one that is mass
times velocity is really
this whole combination,
is mass times velocity.
Because if it's mass times
velocity, this term, 1 over 2m,
the mass squared times
velocity squared,
that gives you kinetic energy.
So we have to be aware that
the canonical momentum is not
necessarily the simplest,
most intuitive object.